From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Good morning. I'm Emily Crosby and we're here at the University of Southern Mississippi with Dean Eddie Holloway on December 2nd, 2015 as part of the Civil Rights History Project,
which is co-sponsored by the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
And with me are John Bishop and Guha Shankar.
And well, good morning.
Good morning.
Thank you so much for doing the interview with us today.
Could you start by telling us when and where you were born?
Eddie Holloway born 1952, September 26th, Hattiesburg, Mississippi.
Can you tell me about your family and growing up?
Yes, my mother and father, Beatrice Holloway.
Actually, she was a Gibson before she moved from York, Alabama and my father, Willie Holloway, was native to Hattiesburg, Mississippi.
What kind of work did your parents do?
My mother was a beautician and I guess when her joy of fishing became as prominent, you could say she was a local fisherman.
But my dad was a service provider and worked at the Meridian Fertilizer Company, which was a precursor to coastal chemicals.
They made various ancestry fertilizers and I think the home office was Yazoo City, Mississippi.
And his can't claim to fame and my bragging point is that he worked there for in excess of 60 years.
Oh my. It's a long working home and one place.
Yes, he told me when he went there, they paid her dollar a day and bet you couldn't make a dollar a day.
So was it peace did they pay for peace work?
Well, he indicated that his task primarily was delivering fertilizer by the barrel from one location to the other.
And the work was so extreme, again the pay was a dollar a day but they would bet you another dollar that you couldn't make a day.
You could actually last the whole day?
Yes, so that was a two dollar a day work.
And through the course of time he became the office custodian and even after the days of his retirement, the insurance of the company required that personnel be present at all time.
So he stayed on the location as a watchman if you will.
He was proud to his final illness.
So he worked his almost entire life?
His entire life, yes.
Did he like working for that company?
I think he loved maybe not the work but the people.
I've until yet to find anybody that will make a statement ill of his being, his day-to-day walk.
Many tell me that he would not sign a contract, he said that's my word.
And I occasionally see people that still recall him for those attributes.
So he was, maybe somebody people trusted?
Until now he's the best person that I ever remember meeting.
Your father?
Yes.
That's right.
I wonder if we're feeling well, imagine.
In where did your family live on Mobile Street?
904 Mobile Street.
And where was your mom's shop?
My mom's shop was attached to the house.
Bees Beauty Salon.
Can you describe Mobile Street?
Mobile Street was a self-contained street as I remember it.
Unless there were extreme needs, most of your needs were met inside of that Mobile Street area.
There was a movie theater.
There were probably 12 to 15 restaurants of some kind or the other, or taverns, or clubs or nightclubs or restaurants.
As many beauty salons or barbershops, there was a physician's office, a dentist's office, a pharmacist.
A couple of have-adassuries, tailor shops, at least six cleaners, four churches, a television repair shop, a watchmaker.
At least four motels, if you will, a hotel, if you will.
A couple of dance halls.
And I would say the professionals of Hattiesburg, Mississippi lived in that area.
And was that really the heart of a black community?
That was the black community.
Right there in that circle of people.
Correct.
Were the residences and the businesses were they sort of interspersed or was there a stretch that was just businesses within the United States?
Yeah, that was probably a four to five, maybe more stretch of businesses.
And for the most part, the businesses were not co-mingled with residential living unless there would be a residential structure on the same lot behind or beside a business.
What was it like for you as a young person to grow up in that atmosphere?
I remember happiness.
It appeared from a towel's eye to live across the street from a school principal or to live next door to a teacher or to live across the street from executive types, if you will.
The staffed the insurance office on what will be a street ought to go to church with the same people that lives in the catchment area of your house.
There were always plenty of motivation intrinsic as well as external if you aspire to be.
Did you frequent the businesses and would you be in that part of the community and go to the movie theater?
I would go to the drugstore.
I would go to the cleaners from the time of my mother's birth every Saturday I would go to Williams cleaners to sit with Miss Thelma Williams because she cleaned my clothes from the point of my mom's death.
Although I was not required to go up there, I felt an obligation to go to sit with her because she would be there dispensing clothes by herself.
So you keep her company?
Was it busy?
The mobile street was so busy. There were points when you would have to exit the sidewalk to get into the street to traverse because it was a catchment area for 30 mile radius.
All of the people in the McLain, Beaumont, Richton, areas, Wiggins, they would come to the mobile street area for beauty purposes, for clothing, for groceries.
Every Saturday.
Did Camp Shelby, was there business from Camp Shelby in the community?
Yes.
I mean, the time that I'm speaking of, Camp Shelby was not an active army training facility as opposed to the service of Mississippi trained personnel.
Okay. So was it just a training facility during World War II?
Yes. It was a training facility for World War I and II, but it primarily went for summer training camps and other trainings.
It's always been an active training facility, but with less activity on the National Front.
So was that like National Guard preparations?
Of course, at certain points National Guard personnel would come from various in the country or other states, but in terms of what I understood it to be at a point when there were 100,000 military personnel at Camp Shelby, but they would come into the city.
That hasn't existed for quite a while.
I know that I've heard that during World War II, which is really boosted in economy and income.
What were you, where did you go to school, what were your schools like?
Well, initially I would have to see my kindergarten, the Maddie Robinson kindergarten, which was two and a half blocks from my house on New Orleans Street.
And following that enrolled in W.H. Jones Elementary, Junior High School, which opened 1958 was my first grade year.
I stayed there through nine years and then went to Royal High School, located on Royal Street, but later changed to Martin Luther King Avenue.
So you mentioned that W.H. Jones Elementary and Junior High opened in 1958.
So I'm assuming it's one of the schools that was built after the Brown decision.
Correct.
Were you aware of that at the time?
Or were that, you know, what the impetus to sort of once the court ruled on integration,
and you specifically tried to make separate buddy cool more real?
Okay. No, I was not at that time in 1958.
But shortly after, somewhere prior to 64, 65, I remember hearing some of the educators discussing that.
As I told you, my mom died. And Mrs. Sip, who was president of the Mississippi Teachers Association, lived across the street.
There was an MTA (Mississippi Teachers Association) and an MTA (Mississippi Teachers Association). One catered to the African American teachers and the other two Caucasian teachers, but handing out of those houses.
And I would say I was not the most athletic type.
There would always be playing in the street.
I would be in with one of them somewhere in an encyclopedia.
And obviously, not welcome to listen to their conversations, but finding myself intrigued by some of the things that they were saying.
And so as a result of those things, I did learn of the state's effort to stime me, full wholesale integration or desegregation by the building of schools such as W.H. Jones and Lillie Burney.
And that was a wave that continued throughout the state of Mississippi.
You mentioned the two separate organizations for teachers, for people that don't know.
And I think the Mississippi Teachers Association was primarily African Americans.
I remember being out of school and I remember that two days Monday Tuesday was set aside for black teachers.
And Thursday Friday was set aside for white teachers.
So when you say set aside, did they have a meeting?
A meeting place in Jackson.
And so the white teachers would meet first.
Well, I can't say which ones, but they did not meet together right.
Well, you mentioned earlier that your mother passed away.
How old were you when she passed away?
11.
And at that point, you started spending more time with some of the teachers in the neighborhood.
And I was always involved or connected by virtue of her being a beautician and most of them would come around.
And as I told you, the majority of my teachers were members of my church.
So even prior to her death, I would go to church with them because they live next door.
Or I would go to teachers' meeting because they live next door.
Or I would be there with one of their friends, excuse me, one of their children and we'll go along with them.
So church was almost an extension of the school.
Can you describe that a little bit for people sort of how the sort of interconnection between church and school?
Well, Mrs. Moore was my quiet director, if you will.
Her sister-in-law, Mrs. Wilson, was my quiet director.
Mrs. Moore, Mrs. Dice, was my third grade teacher and she was my Sunday School teacher.
And I would go to church with her every time she went.
Mrs. Knight, my fifth grade teacher, was my Sunday School teacher.
And they were all superintendents of Sunday School or educational services.
And our church, Mrs. Murdersrugh, who worked in conjunction with my second grade teacher, was a Sunday School teacher at Mount Carmel Baptist Church.
Throughout the course of my earlier years in the environment, they were the same faces at different places.
So in Sunday School or in church, they would know whether I was doing well in elementary school and vice versa.
And we were anchored in the community living next door, three doors down across the street from.
So the educational voids that may have existed in my house were filled by virtue of my wanting to meet the expectations of those that were taking me with them everywhere.
So I guess I'm sorry, I want to go in a couple directions. So it sounds like from a very young age you were hungry for education.
Is that true assessment?
Yes, I don't know what I, hungry for education as opposed to I really wanted to be informed.
I really wanted to know.
And I knew that there were things of importance that I did not know.
And I would see the way that the teachers and the principals would dress.
I would observe their cars and see their walk and their gate and the spunk of which they would get about.
And I know I remember wanting some of that.
So it appeared that the pathway to getting that was to impart be like them.
Sounds like you were very much looked up to them.
Correct.
You said whatever educational void there might be in your home, how far did your parents were they able to go to school?
I don't know because my dad told me that he did not go to a Ureca school. He said he went to the Little Red Building.
And from all I can gather, the Little Red Building was really a little yellow house.
Now it may have been read at a point for him.
And I tried desperately to find out about that Little Red House.
With the history of Ureca High School, I do find that there was a Little Red House.
But I'm sure at that time, six grade or so, my mom, I don't know.
But I knew, I remember one of the struggles that I had was every day when I'd get out of school, my dad would have a cardboard table on the porch waiting for me to get my lesson
before I could go out of the yard.
And we really struggled.
He referred to a zero as an alt.
And that gripped me to knowing to the point of me absolutely saying despite his ability to count that he was archaic,
or that was old fashioned, or that wasn't current, or I don't need you teaching me.
And every day challenged for me.
So I think from that assumption, and from his writing, that I gathered that he was not formally educated.
And certainly not like Miss Sip, Miss Cole, or the Wilson's.
He didn't go.
And then he was overalls to his work every day.
That didn't remove my love for him.
And it still today doesn't distract from me saying he was the best person that I know until this day.
But I knew he was not formally schooled.
So you know, are there things that you learned from him, lessons that you want to learn from him?
Oh, goodness, my daughter today at 31.32 has asked me to write things down, and he's seen it.
I've had a life of challenge.
And I don't say that with regret.
I don't say that certainly for any pity or concern.
But I cannot recall a life's challenge.
That in a moment of silence, a being sequestered from other person places of things,
that I can't recall something my day had told me that'll let me out of that.
So I think he was extremely wise.
I think I'll remember to say nothing to do with him, but I remember getting my first car.
And a guy came by riding on a bicycle with a big boom box, and he said, Eddie, I hear you got to your car.
I said, yeah, he said, what kind did you get?
I said, a Monte Carlo.
He said, man, that's a shiverly.
I said, yeah, he said, why you didn't get a GTO?
I said, I don't know anything about GTO.
He said, so what's wrong with the shiverly?
He said, man, that's a poor man's car.
So I went on the porch and I said, daddy, is the shiverly made for poor man?
He said, well, first son, why are you asking me this?
I said, well, a guy just told me that a shiverly was a poor man's car.
And a Pontiac was for a rich man.
He said, wasn't the guy that just stopped by here?
I said, yes.
He said, I'm ashamed of you, baby.
I said, why?
He said, son, he's on a bicycle.
So he told in silence, very kind, never a gruff word.
I don't think I've ever heard him say damn or heal,
but I can recall his wisdom.
Does that make sense?
Yes.
You must have had a big impact on your family to raise your mother.
You said you were an only child.
Only child.
Do you have any memories of those days about how you and your father co-cute that?
Well, it was an abrupt set of circumstances.
My aunt came the same day from Alabama and her daughter and husband.
And she remained with me until the last day of school.
And they took me to Alabama.
That has to be the beginning of my civil rights history.
They were wise but totally uneducated, formally.
But they lived and breathed civil rights, voting, watching the news every day.
Oh, did they love Martin Luther King and all of the civil rights workers.
And they were consumed with getting an education,
becoming educationally astute and to fight poverty.
They instilled in me a heaping dose of pride, pride in person,
pride in appearance,
pride in the speech decor, never borrow, never request, never be,
put your best foot forward every day.
And that was so overwhelming to me.
They would take me to the lower echelon areas of the city of Birmingham
and take me to the steel mills on payday and to see the people coming from the long companies
to be paid, try to the people getting their chicks.
They would show me the mothers with kids on their hips waiting for the men to be paid.
And I remember I was talking about it just yesterday.
They said, eat, and our life and our death don't embarrass us like that.
We'll be gone.
We never had children, but you uphold our standards.
You save every month.
You go to church every Sunday.
You work every day.
You don't beg for nothing.
Earn your respect.
That has come with the penalty because all that I have traversed and been with didn't understand that.
So it never has been that I've been so egotistical that I saw myself better than others.
But I guess I have tried to live up to an ears and louises and eight punches.
Eat it that your mother's gone.
We won't be here long.
You might have to depend on yourself.
So they lived in Birmingham and then?
They lived in Bessemer, Alabama, which is 12 miles from Birmingham.
And this must have been 64.
64, 65.
Every holiday, every weekend, or every period of time when there was school without I'd take that train that next morning at 8 o'clock and go there.
Bicycle, baseball, and during the earlier years they would send my books
because the principal would cross the old diagonally across the street.
So he would know my classes that I needed.
And they would box those books and send them to me in Alabama.
And how long did you stay with your relatives in Alabama?
Every summer.
Yeah, all but at times when I would get a job of sort,
I disliked it.
They were so strict.
I mean sometimes two, three, four baths a day.
And even to the point of ironing your handkerchiefs and your underwear,
they were meticulous.
They ironed paper bags for Lewis to take his lunch to the steel meals.
So they said that if you would show a wrinkle bag,
it would indicate that that bag had been used before.
So yes, their concerns were to an extreme,
but I never lost focus of what their intentions were.
I know I grew weary of them.
As a young boy.
But I know that I would always need to go see them.
I know that I would always need to call them.
Puyland School here.
They would send me clothes.
Some of which I would want to wear.
Others I'd want to get rid of.
Were you allowed to do that or did you have to wear them?
Oh, I could not because they may come down and want to see them.
So I just didn't wear them.
I didn't wear the red socks or the pink socks or the yellow socks.
But I knew on a given day I would get a letter or a package or a phone call of love.
I knew that I had everlasting friends and relatives.
And they would make sure I knew that.
That the others around me didn't care like they care.
You just mentioned that your aunt and uncle would send you these packages.
Oh, yeah.
Bright colors and stuff.
Yeah, in something magazine.
I don't know what JC Penney or Sears, they would see combination of yellow shirt, yellow socks, red shirt, red socks.
Oh, and that's what they would send me in the mail.
And I tried it.
But as I told you, I won't wear red socks anymore.
What happened when you wore?
Oh, they asked me did I step on a nail that my ankles were bleeding.
That was it.
You find a friend to share those red socks with?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You said that they really introduced you to civil rights.
Yes.
It was very fiery about it.
In 1964, so if you're in Birmingham or Bessimer, right next to Birmingham in 1964, that would have been right after the big demonstration.
Correct.
Did they participate in that?
No, they did not march.
They would be ones that would have given as much money as they could.
They would have gone to the church meetings.
Would have participated by virtue of their social clubs that they would belong to those clubs who make donations to funds that would be used to bond people out of jail.
I can remember their interests consuming them inside of the walls of their home.
But they weren't ones that would be rallying in the street.
They would have been at that time 60 plus years of age.
I was telling my family on the day goodness.
They were 65 when they took a little key in at 11.
How gracious.
That sort of explains at least some of their expectations for you.
Did you ever, I don't exactly know how much was going on in Birmingham at that particular time, but did they ever take you to mass meetings?
No, they took me to the 16th Street Baptist Church.
They would take me to the Say Hey Burger restaurant.
That was Willie Mays.
They would take me to the Birmingham Black Barons stadium where Willie Mays and others played.
They would show me the beauties if you will of Birmingham.
When you say they took you to the 16th Street Baptist Church, were they talking to you about the bombing there?
Yes.
And other civil rights locations.
You remember what you thought about that as a young man?
You would have been almost the same age as the little girls.
I don't think I understood what was really going on at the time.
I knew that there were separate facilities.
I knew that I would have to work as hard, if not harder, to share in the beauty and the wealth of the country.
I know that I would have to, according to them, to be able to assimilate with attitude and with presentation.
Because they, everyday, manners, table manners, greetings, poster.
Those silent teachings that I may have not fully understood, but was trusting of them enough to accept going to church,
going down and asking the church to pray for me because my mother had died and to give me wisdom and knowledge.
Ask for wisdom and knowledge.
That was everyday.
Ask for wisdom and knowledge because once you leave us to go back to Haddie'sburg, you don't have that.
They were speaking of relatives as such.
They were ethnocentric.
They wrote the word on that.
I'm not so sure that they did not try to take me from my dad.
I think that was never a discussion of my consciousness, but I sensed by virtue of him always saying to me,
never let anybody talk to you against me.
Now, I'm not sure of all of that.
I was never really a father.
But I was not able to affirm that.
They never told me that.
I asked them that.
What made you think you might not speak?
I had heard Scuttle but in the street.
But never was able to confirm otherwise.
Berserotificates, all of that.
I mean, it's solid.
But I remember praying that if he lived to a hundred, never let that become an issue in his mind that I had heard that.
Because he certainly didn't have any sense that he didn't treat you like.
He treated you like a person.
I've ever made in my life.
Okay.
So you talked about your relatives coming and supporting you after your mother passed away.
And earlier you talked to me about the community right around.
And that you had a lot of teachers right there who really kind of took you under their wing.
Can you talk about that a little bit?
I think those teachers knew that the path to economic education and life freedoms all connected to education.
And for some odd reason I believed it.
I believed because they told me that.
And I believed because my aunt and my cousins told me that.
And I believed it because my dad would always say,
get your lesson, get your lesson, get your lesson.
And additionally, that was what I call porch people.
So when I would walk from W.H. Jones as I walked past all of those houses, the people on the porch was saying,
you get your lesson a day.
You're going to be smart.
Be smart.
So I knew that there was some connection between getting your lesson, earning a living and having more than it would take just for a meager lifestyle.
So it sounds like you're getting encouraged in that direction everywhere in your life?
Those porch people, just sort of not go about it.
They were there and they always asked about school.
I don't know why, but I think they knew that the core effort to making life better started with school.
And one even said, and I told you I didn't play a lot of ball didn't go here and there, but I would listen to what the law folk would say.
One told me, son, there's a reason that people are killed when they try to go to get an education.
It must be something in education that will set you free.
I never knew what that meant.
But when you looked at the integration of school or going to the separate facilities of saw all those other kinds of things, it really had an education connection.
And so they were really talking directly about this resistance to school desegregation?
I think that's what they were talking about.
The people are that determined to keep you out?
There was some high value to it.
You mentioned earlier that you heard that when you first went to school, you didn't connect it to Brown or a young person.
But over time you heard the teachers talking about that.
You recall what they said?
Oh, and I later affirmed it with the University of Southern Mississippi that it was known and strongly forecast that desegregation and integration would be a reality.
But that in the state of Mississippi and other likewise states massive efforts to save that led to the funding of new schools so that it became a bargaining point, if you will, that would save it all for years to come.
So I've I've I've since that prior hearing N.R. Burger and all those other people talk about that and then learn to see that as a as a truth.
Were they do recall did were they happy? I mean, I'm sure they were happy to have the new building, but did they?
I guess how did they feel about the new buildings versus an actual integration in the school?
I think they were exuberant about the new building because the real stalwarts of education, I don't think pushed integration.
I think they thought with equal footing, financing and resources, Roe and could be as good as had his burger.
I don't know that from those old warriors that they pushed and promoted desegregation from the perspective of we're happy to be integrated.
I think they wanted the everyday attendance, money to be equal. I think they wanted new books and as opposed to one microscope in the biology lab to one per key as in other schools.
I remember seeing one new textbook in the month of October or November in 1968 and that was a geometry book.
How did it sneak through?
Well, they didn't have any to send us. We always got our books from one of the other predominately Caucasian schools, but I'm sure they didn't have any anyway because obviously September passed in October 2, so we finally got new books.
You mentioned N.R. Burger, can you tell us about N.R. Burger?
I think he was a visionary. Before his time.
What was his role in the community for people who don't know who he was?
He was an educator and principal at Eureka, Wall Street High, and Rowan High School.
And as I have said, there had to be a connection with him being so intellectual for the reason that he chose Cornell University to do graduate work as opposed to Brown or University of Missouri or Indiana like many others.
The current superintendent of public schools in Hattiesburg had gone to Cornell.
And N.R. Burger mastered, if not the classes that Dr. Blair had.
And I think demonstrated that he was on par if not above and beyond his abilities.
So I think the freedoms that N.R. Burger were allowed or given or took led him to build a school system in Hattiesburg second to none, though not integrated.
And so you think it was a very deliberate choice on his part to go to the same institute?
I think so.
You mentioned earlier that Hattiesburg was one of the few places in the state in the forties that had high school, 12th grade for African Americans.
What was the impact of being one of the few places that had that?
Well, the reason I had a conversation with N.R. Burger's son and others,
that were people coming from a catchment area around 50 miles to live here if they had a house or bedroom available so that their kids could achieve a high school diploma.
Otherwise, eighth, ninth grade would be the end of it.
Hattiesburg was just a feeder program to Alcorn State University since the lion's share of our educators were from Alcorn.
And I'm sure there were those that were Dr. N.R. Burger today and then I'm sure N.R. Burger were others to that.
You mentioned that your Alabama relatives were very interested in voter registration.
Was your father, did your father try to register?
My father never voted.
I never was able to get him to vote.
Did he talk to you about why he didn't want to or wouldn't?
I can't recall comments to that, but I think he valued his relationships with whites of power.
I think he didn't want to do anything where he would be seen as different.
And he would say things like, I'm paving away for you.
And that he did.
I don't know of any way I went downtown as a 16, 17, 18 year old that some degree of openness didn't come to me as a result of a relationship that he had.
And when you say downtown, that's the right thing.
Correct.
And so people there had an idea who you were because of your father?
I think so to an extent.
Which makes it a safer place for you.
Correct.
I think I still had to earn my way, but I don't think I had to jump the thorned edges that many others.
I don't think I would have to go through three tiers of screening as to allow me to buy a watch on credit because Willie Holloway had an account there.
Or to the service station or to the nurse, I mean, to the pharmacy or places of that kind.
Did you go downtown much?
Yes.
So there were things that you could get downtown that you couldn't get on Mobile Street?
Oh, I mean, you had an account at Sears, JC Penney, Bill Whitley.
I had accounts, my mother had accounts at various and sundry stores, bins, taillard shop, various other places that I would go with him.
So more selection.
Correct.
You mentioned that your mother had the beauty shop.
Did you spend much time there when she was still living?
Yes, for the most part, in there when she was dressing hair as they called it then.
Did you listen to the conversations?
What was that like as a person?
Yes.
At that time, children were not afforded the rights to linger.
But how would pick up on snippets of hot topics?
I talked to Ms. Conner the other day and she said that, actually I don't think she said it the other day,
but I read it in the interview she had done that some of the civil rights workers were specifically trying to talk to beauticians and midwives and encourage them to join the movie.
Do you know if anybody talked to your mother about that?
I don't recall that.
And Ms. Conner lived three doors for me.
So I was in out of that house.
I was in effect, I just came from seeing her son in the cumolesson home Sunday.
So I came up in that house as well.
Didn't Frank and I?
Yes, so you roughly the same age?
Same age?
I think 15, 20 days apart.
Wow.
It's almost like a twin brother.
Correct.
Did any of your teachers talk about voting in the regular schools?
Only when I got to the 9th or 10th grade, Ms. Berger, Ms. Sandefa, N.R. Burger, Mr. Clarence McGee, those were topics of voting at that time.
So they would encourage students to register.
When you were of age?
Yeah, we weren't of age at that time.
But topics of voting were discussed in class.
Do you know if that was part of the formal curriculum or is that they're taking liberties to do that?
I would think there would have been more liberties than courses on civics.
Of course, they have that now, but my understanding is that it was a taboo subject according to the white student attendance.
Right.
And in the book, Count them one by one, which is in a count of the voting rights efforts in Hattiesburg.
Yes, out of Boston, yes.
I'm sorry, I missed what you were saying about the book.
Yes.
I'm just saying that at that era, that era in time, Theron Lynd was a discussion all over the city of Hattiesburg.
People talking from time to time, and it's centered on African-Americans voting.
But even prior to that, there were a group of 15 and more that attempted to vote.
So you remember those conversations in the community about that?
Oh, certainly, yes.
What did you think about it?
I accepted that Black folk couldn't vote.
I accepted that there were separate facilities.
I didn't accept that that would be permanent, but I accepted that that was the status quo.
I accepted that that would be those that would agree to that.
But I knew that that wouldn't be permanent.
That in time, things would change.
What's your first memory of race?
Of an understanding of sort of the rules of white supremacy?
I don't know of the first.
I remember of a consciousness of being invited to USM to attend a quasi-student council, something, something of students, and being the only African-American president.
There has never been an account or time that I can't recall that I was Black or different.
I was always, I mean, my folk in Alabama made me aware of that.
Did you always remember that?
This is the way you act as a result of that consciousness.
But probably sitting in that meeting, I remember it was hot in the head on a wall, cool.
That was the only good I had.
I remember saying one day I'd go out to wear this wall, cool.
In me.
In Mississippi.
I've always, if there's any gift that I've had, and I say this without ego, I think I've always thought of possibilities.
And I've always thought of reframing a situation, despite the current circumstances of it, that there would be, there's a way out of this.
And I remember reading that you're successful if you've got six payments of your salary in a man-made jaw in the bank.
Can we?
And old have I felt so fortunate since I've been dead.
Do you have it in the man-made jaw?
A little bit.
Keep it handy, right?
What are the first civil rights activities that you remember in Hadestburg?
The marches and the mass meetings.
They were almost nightly mass meetings from true light Baptist Church to St. Paul, to Mount Zion, Baptist Church to Palmer's Cross and the marches.
I attend the meetings.
But again, as young, one of the luxuries, if you will, was after my mom's death, being able to go fairly freely.
Well, you were just going to be at home. My mom would go at the, go on the back porch around.
Because she'd had to be five minutes to six or something, but she would whistle.
And I mean, you can hear two, three blocks away. That was your signal?
Let's get home.
Or certainly, the street light didn't catch you away from the house.
She was a strong-wield person.
I say that they did all the way with kids.
I needed my mom for about ten minutes.
I didn't need a police officer just my mom.
So after she passed, then I was able to go to some of the mass meetings.
But not caught blocked. I mean, I had to be back here in the day 39.
Or there would be a responsible person who, it's my dad, would let me go with.
And one of those summers, relatives came from Muskegon, Michigan.
And they were down and I had probably more leverage, more fun, more freedom than I ever had.
I'm guessing your dad didn't go there.
No, my dad didn't go.
What were the meetings like to you?
It would have been the first time I'd been in an integrated meetings with whites.
It reflected to me hope and freedom.
You know how they said they trained elephants and at babies they put chains around one of the feet.
But over time after they are inculcated into that mindset that the chain turns into a small string.
It's a mindset.
Well, just hearing that the freedom writers, and just the name, they were freedom writers that they were coming to set us free.
But I have to say this.
My dad, despite his hesitancy, to be involved in what we call the civil rights movement,
he never spoke to me in terms of, I had limits of achievement.
I mean, he never said, I wanted to go to Haddishburg High School.
And Miss Conninson, Danny Went, my kids, Jeffrey and Taney, that I lived without the mom died when, not of them went.
I wanted to go.
And my dad said, baby, let me ask Miss Eddowne, she was a white lady, that man is the office at the fertilizer place.
Now until this day I don't know whether he lied or not.
But I couldn't wait until he got back home.
I said, Dan, what did he say?
He said, she said, things are going well, where you are, you need to stay there.
I can't discount that.
But I know I couldn't have been more happier than being at Rowan High School.
I don't think, because Danny came back, Jeffrey came back, Jesse came back,
all those that I know went, came back and didn't graduate of Field, or face some kind of challenge.
Were you disappointed when you said that?
And so when you say, now, today you couldn't have been happier than you were at Roe and is that in retrospect, did you have some sense of that even at the time?
I don't think I would have had to pride that Rowan High School was pride.
Give a man a fish, he'll eat today.
Teach a man to fish, he'll eat for a lifetime.
That's what those folks would take that stage every day and tell you.
He who knows and knows not that he knows not, he needs to be taught.
I wouldn't have gotten all of that.
I wouldn't have gotten, you know, I look at Danny, I look at all those others, I'm not naked.
I'm not negative to them.
But that was what I needed, where I was.
So if Miss Edner made that decision, or if my daddy made that decision, that was the right decision for Eddie Holloway.
You said that you mentioned Danny and others who went, transferred, and this is, I assume freedom of choice, to the White School, had his bird house.
And that all the ones you know came back to the Black Schools.
Well, let me say not all, but a significant number for whatever reason.
Did they talk to you about why they came back?
No. But even today as we get together, as in reunions, those that went to Hadisbury High.
For whatever reason, still come to our reunion.
Why?
I've never been man enough to ask.
Why don't you go to your own reunion?
I've never been there.
But there was something, there's something.
Does that make sense?
We just had a gathering, this past summer, all of them came.
And I wanted to say, well, you didn't go to school.
I'm a union graduate with us.
But I never, I wouldn't have seen it.
The children who transferred over there, do you know what their motive, did they make that decision?
Did parents make that decision?
I think in part their parents.
I think they thought the grants was greater.
The water was colder.
And they may have gotten better, pitty-go-gy, but not love, understanding, a third eye or a third eye.
I can assure you that.
Do you think any of them, any of the parents, just thought somebody had to do it?
Do you think they really thought it was better or they did?
Well, I think they thought it was better.
I think by far.
I think many parents thought it was better.
Because I heard them say.
Is that because the equipment, because it's white, is it the resources at the schools?
I think all of them.
All of the above.
And I think I asked you this already, but I'll ask it again.
Did they talk to you about the kind of harassment that they experienced in those schools?
I've heard just a conglomerate of things like that.
I have to believe it because they say it.
But I never experienced that in my life.
I was the first student out here as a resident assistant.
I was the first student of color as an officer assistant.
And I don't say this with ego.
I was the first to staff, Elam Arms, which was an upscale, 455.
Mill Residents' house that was home that was private, swimming pool, turned back service, food catered by.
Morrison's.
I've never experienced that.
What year did you come out here?
In the 1960s, Washington, DC, right in that building.
How did you get that job?
I was standing on the corner and I asked the man, do you know where I could find work?
And he called me a little and that even.
You were in high school then?
Yes.
Was this during the school year or summer job?
Summer.
Summer?
What was it like to work over here doing working in the kitchen?
I mean, it was washing dishes.
I had washed dishes at southern air hotel.
I had washed dishes at the grease from the hotel.
So, washing dishes?
And so, I'm assuming all of the black workers, all the workers, wrapped in American in the kitchen?
Yes.
So, were there people you moved by the community?
Unuming.
You said that you were the first resident assistant.
What year did you come out here to school?
1970.
Did it make a difference to you coming here to school that you had actually already worked on campus?
No.
Actually, Miss Sip and N.R. Burger and all of those that I just, that I have referenced.
They wanted me to go to Jackson State All-Core.
My choice to go to USM was because of my father was living and I needed to be somewhere where I could hate an assistant.
My dad remarried.
Over you, my dad?
15.
Okay, well, that.
You enrolled out here at Southern in 1970.
That's about five years after the first African American go on campus?
Correct.
Because I was okay.
And I believe you said that you moved both of the young women who were...
They came to our mother's, a beautiful and their mother's and grandmother's did.
Did you have an opportunity to talk to them about their experiences before you came out?
We sung in the church choir.
Yeah, yeah.
What did they say about it?
I never had direct conversation with them other than...
I would say that Elaine, I'm strong and I were relatively close.
Miss Branch was an older person.
So she was fairly really remote to the fiber of the school.
Elaine lived on campus, sung in the choir, traveled with the team, the choir in Mexico, the whole world.
So, I don't think I need an explanation.
I was fairly independent at that time.
I remember taking a bus, getting off the bus out here, taking off school that day, letting the council know I was going to be out, coming out here, applying for school,
to take the ACT test and kind of that's the rest of that was history and I said if I didn't make...
If I were not admitted, I'd try William Carey or...
So I had probably had at that time met a couple of people that worked during the summer's own recreational facilities and they were students of USM.
They would have been graduate students.
Are these whites there?
Yes.
Any more good relationships with them?
I cannot sit here and tell you of walls that have here with White Folk.
I put my plan for the Resonance Assistance job.
They moved me for room 33364, Scott Hall, to 411.
I asked, why were you moving me and they said, you're planning for a Resonance Assistance job?
I said, yes.
They said, we don't have one at this time, but see if you'd like it.
I mean, I think I was insightful enough to know that they were putting me on 411 because it was an all-white floor and to see if I could relate to White Kids.
And those guys became my best friend.
Edward Wong and all those guys and the next year they offered me the head residency for the entire hall.
So were you in R.A. that year when you moved here?
Without pay.
So you did a year of voluntary R.A.
And then you came here?
Didn't like it that it was volunteer, but knew that it was a pathway and a stepping stone that my day would come.
So you lived on campus, even when you were in the office to stay in town to be near your dad?
Yes.
What made you decide to live on campus?
Well, I could get my meals.
Okay.
And I didn't have a car.
It was a lot easier to be on campus.
Correct.
So one of the things we sort of have skipped is the Freedom Schools.
Yes.
How did you get involved in the field school?
Well, all up and down, we'll be a street where freedom libraries around at that time it was called the Black folks Library.
It was really the community center.
There were Freedom School efforts.
And then there were Freedom School efforts at the True Light Baptist Church.
I would go for not every day.
I'd go and get a book from the library.
I would go to some of the meetings.
But the old folk in Alabama,
they really instilled in me a sense and response mindset.
I remember going, I've never told this.
But many of those kids appeared to be just a maciated impoverty.
They are parents.
They are a sense of without a lack of knowing of where they were.
Being driven there because they were going to give them some food.
And so I was going to tell them,
they weren't trying to either to lose or talk me against it.
They said, go buy your own belongings.
And don't even be real unless you touch the dollar.
So I didn't participate like the other students who would participate.
Many of those that participated, that parents were involved.
But I knew to go get me a couple of books.
I knew to read the encyclopedias of different things like that.
But I didn't do a lot of that stuff.
I marched.
When I was since danger, I would leave.
If we were marching one night up town and we get there,
and I see people that represented the clans with guns.
And I knew all the other guys with me on there,
a couple of bottles, broken a beer bottle.
I'd go home.
I don't want to say I was an outlier.
But as long as I can remember,
I've been an independent thinker.
I hope that's best to describe it that way.
Sounds like it.
Did you ever sit in classes?
Did you ever participate?
Not just the library, violin, or books, but the three-year school classes.
Yeah, I would go when they were talking about civility, civics.
I would go sometimes when those people,
they would bring in guitarists and they'd play.
But I didn't go at...
I think I got the essence.
I would go around with some of the people knocking on doors
and asking them what they registered to vote.
I would like to say that my environment was kind of structured,
if you will.
Does that make sense?
Do you remember how people would respond
or how you felt when you were doing the canvassing on board?
A preparation for that was how my dad saw it.
He didn't want any part of it.
Though he was not oblivious to the issues of race,
he may have seen himself beyond that.
I don't know who he'd ever discussed it.
But I always said,
what's the benefit of this?
What's the benefit of that?
How might it impact the masses?
So I would be prone to, if I'd go to the doctor,
Dr. A. T. Tatum's office,
and they'd turn,
so you have to go to the back door,
and I would say no,
I'd like to go to the front door.
What's your response?
Well, they asked me out.
So I'd call the Office of Civil Rights in DC.
And Dr. Tatum called me and said,
He'll be your grandmother and my arms at the time of her death.
I've known your daddy best,
man, I know.
But you can't come back to my office.
From that point on,
I don't know what I was a snitch for the government.
I probably never told this either,
But I receive calls from the Office of Civil Rights for 25 years on voting, location changes,
on my opinions on anything changing the boundaries from schools and things that I can.
So quietly I filed objections to separate medical facilities over around the old
Methodist Hospital and Petal Mississippi.
I know that one of the things that civil rights act and then I can't remember what the name of the legislation was that provided more federal funding for medical facilities.
But what both of those did was provide this kind of recourse right where there's Petal over oversight.
When you had that encounter with the doctor, is that like the late 70s?
I mean late 60s, early 70s.
Now what they did was they locked the door from entrance but you would have to go through the front and go back to the same room.
And I remember really being bothered by my dad still went to him.
His sister still went to him and all of those teachers that lived across the street that I taught still went to him.
And I remember that as almost overwhelming.
So they were going to the White Doctor and said the Dr. Schmerk?
Yes. They were going to Dr. Tatum, AT Tatum.
And they were going that front door and going back to that pack.
Do you know why they would see him?
I'm sure family lineage.
It made me also heal out pay if they didn't have insurance.
I think he really think he was a quality physician.
Good strong track record.
Probably have more African American clients than otherwise.
I never saw anything ill about his services.
Do you have any idea how he would answer?
I mean I'm asking you how he would answer.
But you know he's saying to you, I held your grandmother once she was dying.
There's so much intimacy in that.
I mean that's a very intimate thing.
And yet you can't walk in the front door.
Well my conversation with him is that I remember like it was yesterday.
I said Dr. Tatum.
I share seats with your daughter.
And we today are in a political science class.
And we enter the same door.
Her name is Nancy and my name is Eddie.
And she's such a nice person.
So we beat it.
I didn't do that without fear.
At that time I was, I managed the front desk of Scott Hall.
And I had access to master keys for all of the rooms and all of the halls.
So I would stay in various and sundry rooms at night in fear.
And it may have been a false fear.
That's a lot of access for you to have had.
To be able to get in all the rooms.
That was not public.
Only because I worked in the front desk.
Do you remember other incidents like that?
Or challenging those boundaries?
I've always challenged boundaries.
I've always applied.
I always asked for what reason.
I've always thought that if I could equate the other applicants at some point in time.
I'm sure to some extent I would rationalize it as providential if I didn't get it.
The next man wheel.
At least I opened the door.
I applied for a scholarship if you will.
A specialized service training of your choice to help you in provisional conditions.
I can't recall the name of that scholarship.
But anyway, I made it to the third round of that.
I had to go to the Sheridan Hotel in Jackson.
And it was new for an African American back then.
I always wanted to be.
My day would always say, you can't be juged up on wife up around wife of all the time.
But I didn't desire to be jugged up on the wife.
I just desire access too.
But during that interview, the guy said, Mr. Holloway, how are you?
I see you're from Mississippi.
What do you think of this? What do you think of that? What do you think of this?
Do you know James O. Eastland? James O. Eastland?
I say, yes, he's a senator.
He says, what do you think about his service?
I said, well, he's one of two senators, state of Mississippi, John C. Stennis,
and Mr. Eastler.
How do you think of his service?
I say, I think he's an able service provider.
You're the best, right?
I'm doing my best and whatever, whatever.
He said, I don't think much of it.
And I said, okay.
He says, you know, he offered the Farm Subsidy's Act.
He said, what about farmers are paid not to grow crops?
And he had, I say, I know what you're talking about.
I say, he had enough land, he had to master to make 10 farms,
and he was able to develop wealth from that.
And he said, do you know something else?
I say, yes.
Sir, you're not going to be awarded this scholarship
because you said that knowing what you just told me,
and you accommodated me, leaders, walk a weary limb out with.
What did you make of that?
That they are places where you've got to take risks and tell the truth.
So did you apply that lesson?
Ever since then.
I've learned to frame and reframe and do it in a way that it's accommodated
and not so abrupt that it'll take me out of the formula.
I think I've got that line of how to say your piece but do it in a way
that somebody might put it here.
You talked to me earlier about, you thought that N.R. Burger was really a visionary.
Can you talk about, I think we mostly talked about that outside,
and that on the interview.
Can you talk about his role in the community?
Did you talk on the table about his going to Cornell?
I think N.R. Burger was a difficult walk.
It was required that he remain on the inside,
but he was conscious of those things that were paramount to the outside.
A great debate that's under the surface now is his role or his inactivity
or whether he had a role in Clyde Kennard effort to come here.
I'm not sure.
I've asked Dr. Lucas.
I've asked Vernon's son, Vernon Dahmer's son.
I've asked as many the older leaders as possible.
I've heard that since the opposition was so strong for
Clyde Kennard to come here,
then a group of people say it will work to keep Clack out
of the state if you'll finance a junior college and let it be on the financial
adults of the state.
That's a lofty.
That's in perpetuity.
You create a college.
You pay that step for a while.
That seems like the creation of a Berger,
because it would have been Princess to two.
The junior college is now defunded.
That's where he came from.
He lived there, where he's from.
The hallmark of African-American education was in that
printed support Gibson area.
N.R. Burger was always in a negotiating posture.
He was always leading in chaos.
So the end product of his work was a stellar, separate,
but almost equal educational system,
where the average daily attendance and cost per key was significantly less than any other.
So I hold him in high regard, just knowing the little that I know.
But he was able to accomplish his context of his system.
You mentioned Mr. Lucas and asking Mr. Lucas,
is it Aubrey?
Yes.
And he was the registrar at the time.
As he talked about what happened when Mr. Clyde Kennard tried to come out here.
He told me that,
any at the time N.R. Burger spoke with legislators
and the wealthy,
that he was a direct individual,
and that I had, he had limited discussion with him
on the involvement of Clyde Kennard in the process.
I don't know whether that's totally accurate or not.
He also said that
Dr. William D. McCain told him that the state of Mississippi higher education
should be fully desegregated or integrated.
But the place that it should start should be the University of Mississippi,
in that we are one vote away from the closing of this school.
So the delicacy of our standing with the stakeholders
is such that it ought not start here,
that we could be closed overnight.
That's what Lucas told me.
Why would Southern have been at risk of being closed?
He explained that our status with the state board was of that nature.
I don't think I'm led to believe if he's correct,
there was more than just whether Clyde Kennard came here.
But in the disturbance here.
That would be the last.
That would be the excuse.
That's what he's constantly told me over the past 30 years.
That McCain did say he said,
he said McCain said that Ole Miss should be integrated
and leave the way, and it would be perfect if Ole Miss
would be winning the SEC that year.
So successful school quote,
these aggregations in Mississippi?
You know, whether, whether all of that's correct,
I don't know, but that's what in very serious conversations he's told me.
Does he raise that or you raise it?
I've called him and asked him.
We've met.
Yeah.
Because of course he's one of the people that's still living who was actually present for some of that.
Right.
Growing up were you aware of his case?
Oh yes, they talked about it in the beautiful parlour.
But again, keep it mine, through mine's eye.
He was a man who got to go to Southern.
At that time I only knew of one black.
There was that Southern.
His name was Mr. Pally and he sold peanuts.
So he would come out here and stand and sell peanuts.
Big difference.
Yeah.
Did your parents talk about it at all?
No, not in my presence.
But the ladies would in the beautiful parlour.
And keep it mine, Mr. Jean was instrumental always in the inebrile ACP.
So you always had that from Mr. Jean and she was a beautician also.
Up on Mopil Street.
In the 500, 600 block of Mopil Street.
And they had a shoe shine parlour.
And her church, which AME African Methodist Episticle,
has always had a lead in the civil rights.
I'm glad you brought her up again.
We interviewed both Ms. Daisy Harris Conner and Mr. Clarence McGee.
I think you also mentioned as a teacher.
Can you do it great if you could describe them for having this crossover with the interviews?
I think Ms. Conner was a willing worker.
She was hands and feet to the movement.
Found way of records, found way of history and involvement.
Gosh.
She was kind of a...
Mr. Thun.
I remember Mr. McGee.
He was my 10th grade science teacher.
I never was privileged to conversation with him until 15, 20 years ago with his NAACP.
And Favonett.
I think his intentions are honorable.
Some were dated.
And what I mean by that is...
There are some people that would think that the only place you can get a quality education will be all-corn.
And their love and insight for all-corn supersedes the highest order that Harvard University would offer.
I'll put it in his fears.
So I think his limits would prevent inside growths.
So this is a good moment I think to talk about Southern and how much it's changed in the last 50 years.
When I was growing up in the Mississippi, there was still in the 70s and early 80s.
My impression was that there was still a pretty stark divide between the three major white universities and the HBC News.
And so even at that point, I think where we went to school, there was the impression that Southern was the most welcoming of the three white institutions, perhaps African American students.
Can you describe Southern today and how it fits in this, how it's changed?
Well an inside joke is that USM is the Mississippi's fourth HBCU.
I don't know whether that's kind of not to say.
I think it's positive from the perspective that we do a tremendous job to a shoe access.
And we do a tremendous job to provide services to students where they are.
Is it an open access school?
In terms of entrance, ACT and all, no.
It has the same entrance requirements at home and state and all-con valley.
All the schools have the same.
The difference might be that one institution might commit that we're going to recruit 60% from out of state and their financial strength allows for that to occur.
So they may have 60% of their income and students from the state of Texas.
And those may have not been admitted to the University of Texas at Austin, Texas Christian.
Southern Methodists are rice, but they may bring 28 ACTs.
USM's catchment area is roughly 120, 125 miles, primarily first generational.
I hope this does not sound egotistical, but I know what I needed when I got here in 1970.
And since my arrival, I've tried to broaden that across the full breadth of this institution.
From Gondor Dr. Lucas Day-Won, Santa, we need an office of inclusion to talk into athletics about in-service training for guys.
They work with students at risk.
From constantly talking about the need for campus wide, services and civility training.
Because many of the students that will come will be rough on the edge and they'll do things that will jeopardize the educational setting.
The creating an office of a student's office, busman services to deal with those idiosyncces that kids come to school with that average faculty knows nothing about.
To be only 24-hour call to manage the almost all foreseeable and all predictable.
And I think as a result of that, over time through the deficiency or the combination of all, the word is gotten out that you can get from here to there by going to USM.
If that makes sense.
Now, I left USM and went to UK, we came to Kerr University and ran a program called Students Services.
It was for the academic, the high risk that had deficits in three cores, academic, social and financial.
And we tried to make sure that financially the needs were met.
There was tutoring to help with deficits and there was counseling to help with our social efforts.
We ran that program for three years and we went into a catchment area of 30 miles to bring in 100 kids that we leveled the 12th graders to William Kerr plus we worked with them when they were there.
Then I left never wanted education again and went into alcohol and drug treatment, ran four clinics, New Augusta, Columbia, Purvis, Columbia and here at night.
And actually came here in 1979 to work until a friend completed his doctorate in two years at the University of Texas at Denton.
That was how many years ago?
About 37.
But it was kind of.
When you were talking about Southern and Access and you know you can get a good education, you can get reading.
What's the percentage of African American students my campus?
Closing around 40% and my rate that there were more African American students at Southern than in other schools.
Correct.
So that's got to be a tremendous shift from 50 years ago.
Certainly.
But I think we've been accommodating.
I think I really think on that student affairs side, Dr. Joe Paul would have been here the scope of time.
I have been here in Dr. Lucas.
It's been a goal and aim to afford kids access to.
So do you think, I mean, you know my sense is it's somewhat superficial, but that you know even after James Meredith went to Ole Miss,
that the people that followed him continued to really struggle, but it was not a particularly that it remained a hostile space.
But it sounds like you came to Southern five years after the first two students to desegregate it and didn't find that kind of a hostile.
You think that Southern made a different commitment?
You know, if you look at the struggles across the country be it with housing, affordability be it with somebody here in this town,
or some bodies, despite our challenges, cut those sharp edges off.
I think N.R. Burger was a part of that formula.
I think Dr. J. Ralph Noonkester, William Carey, I think they collaborated to integrate William Carey to be the first private college in the state to do so.
N.R. Burger selected those students from Roy and I 1965.
I think that had been a discussion beforehand with N.R. Burger, Dr. J. Ralph Noonkester.
I think N.R. Burger, N.R. Burger, Dr. Lucas, and the powers that be.
I think it got crossed-hired with a lot of people looking at N.R. Burger moving here and there.
That's why I said his walk I think was so delicate.
I think another person involved in that, though a lot of people spoke ill, may have chained.
And others, Moran Pope, a former mayor here leading proponent of the USM.
I think there were enough people that kept talking.
Do you think the fire bombing of the Vernon Dahmer Hall and murder of Mr. Vernon Dahmer did that?
So, there was a wake up call for people.
I mean, I've heard that you mentioned the president of William Carey that Mr. Vernon Dahmer said that he helped try to raise a little bit of money to rebuild the house.
To the white community, to the white community, react to that was sort of like it is really too far.
Is I guess the impression I got into that?
Does that then create more space for the people who want to do something?
I think there has been more willingness to work together than not.
I think in the midst of free and controversy, over time that I'm aware,
they have been the currents of conversations with folk talking that has worked to us not becoming, has some of the cities have.
You mentioned when we were talking earlier that you're on the, is it the Civil Rights Museum Commission?
What's the title of the group?
Civil Rights Commission.
Commission. Can you talk about the commission?
Yeah, it's a Mississippi legislative act that one call for the creation of a civil rights component into the curriculum of the public schools.
I work from the William Winter Institute for Racial Reconciliation with William Winter, Ms. Susan Glisson.
The McCombs schools have done a lot of that.
The schools have done a lot of that.
So we meet monthly, sometimes quarterly, looking at ways of means to best do that.
And I also sit on the Mississippi Coalition Against Sexual Assault whereby we look at it employing tactic skills and programming that prevents stalking.
Violence against women.
Is that a new commission?
No, it's us.
Six to eight years.
So we've pulled to get all campuses in the state to be an arm to minimize, uh, elax of women, female, as well as others, respect for humanity.
So all of those things, uh, I think have led to a, and all of my fortunes, I've tried to bring them locally, a guy that I met in 1970.
Why, okay.
I said, Eddie, I paid for you to be a member of the, and you've been accepted to leadership in Mississippi.
Never heard of my life.
So I went, it's a six month program on developing leadership and making Mississippi better.
And you look at some aspects of the state.
It's status where you would think it could get better and you map and design ways from those study committees that you could make that happen.
Well, once I complete that, came and organized and formed Leadership Hattiesburg, Mississippi.
A wholesale integrated body of young professionals.
We're in our 25th year of staffing 20 people up and coming to make Hattiesburg, Mississippi better.
And as I say before, I'm not in the sand that there are no yields, that there are no situations or impropriety or inequities.
And maybe I'm blind as a, but I believe that attitude, understanding, uh, hard work, not knowing every time that you'll get what you want.
That you could impact humanity by way of race.
I'm not saying even where I've gone, that I've felt welcome, that I've just been an ingratiation that Eddie's here.
But if I sense that there will be another time when I'll have an opportunity to say hello and to build a bridge.
Now sometimes that's misunderstood.
That scene is kissing, hugging inappropriately.
I say you build a bridge.
And it may not be strong enough for me to go across it, but maybe tomorrow someone else can.
Is the Civil Rights Commission involved with the Civil Rights Museum?
Yes, there are two separate boards.
We met with them four or five months ago to see the elements of their preparation for the Mississippi History Museum and the Civil Rights Museum.
So, Mr. Susan Glisson is connected to all.
She's one of the connectors.
And many members and former members of both the ALF.
Yeah, I don't know what the latest is, but can you just tell us a little bit about the plans for the museum?
I'm not familiar with all of the plans other than what I was privileged when I went to there.
They had hired the architect for rendering.
They had hired the programming group to make sure that Mississippi's story was inculcated into the fiber.
But for me, the challenge would be that you must exit with the dream as opposed to exit with an agony.
How do you tell the story?
So, that was my challenge.
People when they exit, they should not be so marked with the negatives that they don't have a dream for the future.
Well, certainly. A lot of movement activism in Mississippi is inspiring even if the results are always what people hoped.
I want to click.
So, what, I mean, you spoke to that, I think a little bit with your comment just now, but what do you want people to know about the Civil Rights Movement?
I think the Civil Rights Movement was a breathtaking eye-opening opportunity to see tomorrow from where we stood.
And to take advantage of those resources that those brought from a yonder here to aid and assist us.
I think the ingenuity and or the strength was with those that were still here.
But because they were so linked and wired to their oppressors, other oppressors, strengths that it would have taken longer had there not been a voice of freedom coming from a wealth of places that could speak to that for us.
So, it gave us a greater opportunity to see life from a distant and to see new possibilities and new beginnings.
And I think those that were wholesale against it could no longer just see it as those people that were basically here that we are taking care of.
And how are they disrespecting our efforts?
But that was a, that it allowed Mississippi, Alabama, Georgia to see that we are behind in the wholesale efforts of equality and services to the least of us.
And that unless there are some economic gains and heaping doses of educational advancement, we will not have a society of people that are able to pursue dreams that will allow them to reap the freedoms of our people.
And that would put this great land of forwards.
That would be a great stopping place, but I did think of another question I wanted to ask you about the movement era.
And I don't know if you would know about, did you know about the spirit?
Yes.
Can you talk about them?
Well, coming up, I never knew who the spirit was.
I didn't know that during the times when schools were, or places where businesses were boycotted, that if you break those lines, that the spirit would visit you during the night, things that they can.
So, what did that mean for people who don't know what the spirit is? What would it mean to be visited in the night?
Well, goodness, I mean, you never knew who the spirit was, maybe your next to a neighbor, maybe person across the street.
I remember the spirit by virtue of me wanting to start cutting hair at 11 years of age.
And I couldn't go to a store and buy hair clippers.
So, I ordered them at age 11 from National Bellas Hess.
I don't know if either of us are old enough to know, is a mail order business.
It was a precursor, maybe, to Best Buy and others, but you could buy hair clippers and pants and luggage and other things.
And it came to the store on Front Street.
It didn't come to your house.
But I couldn't go down there and get them.
So, I remember calling and they mailed me my walls clippers to the house.
So, it was a source of economic steering where it called to the attention of those,
the movers and shakers in our community that people have galvanized, they understand economics to an extent,
and that if you don't afford them access or at least representation in your stores, that their dollars will not be good enough for you.
And unfortunately, in this country, wealth is a motivator.
Frederick Herzberg, but it can be a demotivator.
That in time, if it demotivates, people will act to that.
You know, I was against the effort of the kids there at University of Missouri.
I always had a favorable opinion of University of Missouri.
Dr. Oval Strickland, profound from Hattiesburg, wrote the school song of Euro and Eureka.
It was just premier there. Maybe half dozen of our faculty members had gone to journalism there.
But I don't think any of that would have galvanized until the football team said no.
And that wasn't a million dollars. That was probably 50 million that weekend had they not played.
So, the dollar...
That was going to be a big cost.
And so, what would the spirit do if somebody from the black community would go into one of the stores that was being boy-todders?
From what I remember, they may break your windows at your house or your car or may publicize something to you, love you.
In Hattiesburg, was the spirit also involved in self-defense? Did they do protection as well?
Well...
That's separate groups.
Well, I don't know whether that was the defense. They used to call it the decons of defense or whatever.
And whenever there would be dignitaries come like Dr. King or Dr. Vivian or Shuttlesworth or some of the other people coming to the area, they would provide security.
That would double dose that of their own security as well as what your local authorities would give.
Are there other things you can think of that I haven't asked about that.
That are important.
Well, I would think it would reflect of me in terms of my thoughts relative to leadership and relative to civil rights that...
I think we, in my mind, people that were on the inside of the civil rights movement, maybe were less heralded, but were able to negotiate and accomplish far more than maybe many that had great posture and absorbed the television screens.
You know, somebody had to do the work.
And I've always thought it best for me to work from the inside and to work from the strengths that we have, be of bridges, have open lines of communication.
And from that will come, great outcomes. I would hope that the University of Southern Mississippi, as it looks today, is in part because we did it right.
You know, it's in part because I've not been a silent observer.
You know, I've gone to Dr. Lucas, I've gone to Dr. Tim, I've gone to all of the presidents of things that I see that will benefit this institution.
And in particular, African American students that will come with a wealth of needs.
Still, most of our communities are separate when it comes to residential or of our religious faith.
Still, many students bring to the platform deficits. And in particular, African American students.
And we must be purveyors of good teaching and insightful teachings.
And to know that if it's preventable, if it's foreseeable, you can prevent it.
If it's predictable, you can better manage it. So if you're going to have students coming with low ACT scores, transfer from junior college with great needs, that you should have a service of kind to aid in assisting them, that their failures are in part on them and their families.
But another part of that is on you because you got them here and you didn't do what you took to service them.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. I hope in some way my comments have made sense.
Absolutely. I very appreciate your interview and time with us.
So thanks.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, you just mentioned knowing the ladder sisters from Hattiesburg or Paulmers, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And you tell us about them?
Well, let's see, I shared dinner with them several months ago.
We went to the unveiling of the photo of Clark and Art in DC.
Coming up, they were just household stories of their works at Jackson State in Tougaloo.
And that Palmer's Cross and was a stronghold for civil rights effort.
Kelly Settlement, Palmer's Cross and a lot of people saw those communities as communities of need.
But the strengths were that those people owned their property.
And they found, I guess, they answered the question that God was making people,
but they weren't making more land. So they got them a piece of land.
And the connection of Brown University with Tougaloo, I met Miss Holahan,
Caucasian lady, the first delta in the country, graduate of Tougaloo.
So I've just always been a student.
Is that Joan Trumpauer Mulholland, I don't know what her last name is now?
I think it's her.
Well, she's got another one.
There's a whole of Harlem.
Harlem.
Joan Trumpauer Mulholland.
Yeah.
That's right.
I know you're talking about her.
Yeah, because she was out there Tougaloo with them.
Right.
But they still have relatives and hadies, but just from reading to them.
That's one thing that I failed to tell you.
And I'm sure they missed this at Haddie'sburg High and other schools.
Those instructors would link you to the precursors.
And if there was a person living in Detroit doing well from Haddie'sburg,
Pennsylvania, New York, or California, or they would give you that connection.
And for me, I would always say, gosh, they get to that location from right here.
Yeah, it's interesting because I think both of them,
but I know Dora has been very explicit with me.
You know, she found it so upsetting that with two colleges here in the community,
she had to leave for her education.
It's interesting.
So from your perspective, come behind you see where they go.
Yeah.
And I never expected they wish they had the opportunity to stay like you did.
Well, I just, and again, for me, I never focused on color.
I was sensitive of color and race, but I never focused on it.
I never became a slave to whole limited year,
I bet you they are not going to like me to have that mindset.
Or I've got to do this, and I've got to do that because,
how it is, when I walked on and I saw that all my instructors were Caucasian, I knew
they would feel this.
I mean, I never had that.
I've been conscious that I'm African-American, but I didn't see that as a minus.
Does that make sense?
I saw that there may be things that they don't know that I need to share with them, or
there may be experiences of which they've not been afforded, and I may need to share
that with them.
It's kind of like, in closing out, was in a city and a psychologist came out laughing.
I said, what's going on?
She's not going to believe it.
I said, what?
She says I was doing this psychological assessment on this little girl, and I just had to come
out and then want to laugh in her face.
So, what happened?
She said, I asked her to name three animals, and she said Milton de Masta, Godzilla, and
the book of men.
And she says, that's pathetic.
I say, no.
I always had to go to bed at night in a dark room.
Other book of men was going to give me.
Godzilla was the only movie we had at Star Theatres.
It stayed there ten years.
So in that kid's mindset, those were three animals.
Did that make sense?
So that kid was okay.
I was talking about this student who was in trouble and had an accident from a process.
And actually, probably skilled enough to play on Sunday, if you know what I mean.
But because of his attitude and what he had said, led to him being an accident, the process.
But I think my style has always been to share information and to, for insight purposes.
So if this guy had an opportunity to play for USC or for University of Texas or Oklahoma,
but his grandmother said no, go to USC.
I'm that's closer to me.
And he made that commitment.
And here she comes up and is diagnosed with the possible terminal illness.
He didn't go to class because he called her and she said she was feeling real bad.
But he called the instructor and asked what will be covered.
But on the report that he didn't go to class.
He was aggressively, properly though, disciplined.
But to the point of his pain, he made some very awkward inappropriate statements to the
power they be.
I never thought that I was going to change that power opinion.
But for future references, he needed to understand that this was a grandmother in the absence
of a mother and a father who said she was sick, who said come to Southern Miss instead of
those other lofty programs.
Had the power person asked the right questions, it wouldn't have gone to the extent that it
did.
So what I've attempted throughout my walk is to help those have the necessary insights
to ask the right questions so that they can gain from their view of where the people
or the person is, be it fighting, be it aggression, be it any of the deficits that our kids
bring with him.
They are not excuses for which they should lie on, but they are reasons by which conversation
hopefully will make them benefit.
That makes sense.
So I would hope as a result of those experiences with our students, we have developed a reputation
that students will come from extreme circumstances knowing that all of this is an historically
wide institution.
They will have access to the best and brightest and that the doors will open both ways and
they will find accommodations.
That seems like one of those successes in its role, isn't it?
Yes.
Thank you so much for your time and for sharing with us today.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History and Culture.